presiding officer
first minister
members of the scottish parliament
it is a pleasure to be invited to
address you on this special occasion
i would like to begin by thanking you
for presiding officer for your kind
words of welcome
i would also like to congratulate you
and the scottish parliament as a whole
for being able to mark the new session
of parliament in this safe and welcoming
manner during what has been a very
trying period
presiding officer you carry the weighty
responsibility of being a strong
advocate for the parliament
and i know you will strive to use your
judgment
to lead this parliament by demonstrating
fairness
respect
and impartiality
members of the scottish parliament as we
all step out from adverse and uncertain
times
occasions such as this
today provide an opportunity for hope
and optimism
this new session does indeed bring a
sense of beginning and renewal
the scottish parliament has been at the
heart of scotland's response to the
pandemic
with people across this country
looking to you for leadership and
stewardship
and i hope you will remain at the
forefront
as we move towards a phase of recovery
while some of you will have differences
of opinion
i trust you will continue to work
together
your service here is carried out in the
presence of the mace
and i encourage you to draw inspiration
from the founding principles
of wisdom justice
compassion and integrity
these words are a reminder of your
responsibilities to the people of
scotland
and in the years ahead i hope you can
reaffirm their importance to everything
you do as a member of this parliament
today is also a day when we can
celebrate those who have made an
extraordinary contribution to the lives
of other people in scotland
locally or nationally
during the kovite 19 pandemic
i have spoken before
of my deep and abiding affection for
this wonderful country
and of the many happy memories prince
philip and i
always held of our time here
it is often said that it is the people
that make a place
and there are few places where this is
truer than in scotland
as we have seen in recent times
we all know of the difficult
circumstances that many people have
encountered during the last 18 months
however alongside this they've been
countless examples of resilience and
goodwill
following my grandson's time as lord
high commissioner
prince william has told me many
heartening stories that he heard
firsthand of people and communities
across scotland uniting to protect and
care for those who are isolated or
vulnerable
it is only fitting that we use this
occasion to acknowledge and thank these
remarkable people
who have made such a positive difference
to so many
members of the scottish parliament
as i said earlier
the beginning of a new session is the
time for renewal and fresh thinking
providing an opportunity to look to the
future
and our future generations
next month
i will be attending cop 26 events in
glasgow
the eyes of the world will be on the
united kingdom and scotland in
particular
as leaders come together to address the
challenges of climate change
there is a key role for the scottish
parliament as with all parliaments
to help create a better healthier future
for us all
and to engage with the people they
represent
especially our young people
officer
first minister members of the scottish
parliament
the duke of duchess of rothsay and i
will continue to follow your progress
with the closest of interest
and we extend you all
our warmest good wishes as you embark on
this sixth session of parliament